In genetics, understanding how allele pairs segregate in
all their possible combinations for all the chromosomes, and
then recombine in the offspring at fertilization to produce
all the different genotypes and phenotypes we can get,
is one of the most complicated parts of genetics.
We're only scratching the surface here really understanding what's
going on in miosis. So there's a handy way
of thinking about how these allele pairs separate using
a tool called a punnet square. Now some of you
may have heard of this before. We're going to take a
quick look at how we can use punnet squares to
help us understand this segregating alleles problem a little better.
Let's imagine for a second that we have two parents.
a mom and a dad. These are two individuals here
and we're going to focus only on chromosome two, which has
the lactase gene controlling lactose intolerance. Dad is homozygous recessive
for lactase non-persistence. This means that dad is
going to be lactose intolerant, because he's not going to make
enough lactase as an adult To be able to
metabolize lactose. Mom on the other hand is homozygous-dominant
for lactase persistence. This means mom is going
to be lactose tolerant, she's going to keep expressing lactase
into adulthood. Now the question is, if they have
a child What are the possible genotypes and phenotypes
of their children? This is when our punnet squares
are going to come in handy. Let's take the possible segregated
allele combinations we can have for the dad. If
his pair of homozygous recessive alleles segregate, we can get
one gamete with a recessive allele, and another gamete
with a recessive allele. Now we can do the same
thing for the mom here. She can either pass
on a dominant allele or another dominant allele. So if
we want to figure out what their offspring could be, genotypically,
or what genotype they will be, all we have to do
is fill in this punnet square. Look at this box, combine
the column and the row. We can have a plus and
a minus here. You can have a plus and a
minus here. You can have a plus and a minus here.
You can have a plus and a minus here. It turns
out that all the possible combinations appear to be the same.
So, based on these results, what percentage of the children will be lactose
intolerant, like the dad? Go ahead and put your answer and percentage form here.